- Ils ont déjà la passion
pour le jeu, mais avec
les accomplissements de ces deux
vedettes du tennis canadien,
tous les espoirs sont permis.
SAMILA JAHRAH, joueuse
- Ça aide un peu, oui, parce que
je me dis que si eux sont
capables de le faire, moi aussi,
je suis capable de le faire.
- J'ai commencé à l'âge de six
ans. C'est vraiment intéressant
puisque les deux sont
de vraiment jeunes joueurs
de tennis puis en plus,
ils sont Canadiens.
- Leurs coups de raquette
étaient un peu plus vigoureux,
surtout quand on sait que
Leylah Annie Fernandez s'est
entraînée ici, à Montréal.
MAURICE SACHA DE MAURIVEZ,
joueur
- Elle est de notre club.
En plus, elle est canadienne;
alors, c'est comme, ça nous
apporte beaucoup de joie!
MIRABELA TEODORESCU,
entraîneuse chez Tennis Montréal
- Moi, je trouve que depuis que
le US OPEN a commencé, Félix
aussi et Leylah aussi ont
commencé à gagner et à avancer
de tour en tour. Les enfants
sont encore plus motivés.
Les petites filles m'ont dit,
même hier et même aujourd'hui :
"Mira, c'est soir Leylah joue.
Moi, un jour, je veux être
comme Leylah!"
- À 19 ans, Fernandez,
73e au classement mondial,
a causé la surprise aux
Internationaux des États-Unis,
notamment en éliminant les Osaka
et Kerber. Félix Auger-Aliassime
est également dans le carré
d'as, ce qui laisse croire que
le Canada est en voie de devenir
une pépinière de joueurs
de tennis.
SEVERINE TAMBORERO, dir. du
dévelop. U10 chez Tennis Canada
- C'est énorme, c'est énorme.
Les jeunes qui vont être
inspirés par ça, ça va être
vraiment incroyable à travers
le Canada.
- Avec un travail rigoureux
et assidu, rappelle le père
de Leylah.
JORGE FERNANDEZ, père
de Leylah Annie Fernandez
- Ce n'est pas par chance
qu'elle est là. Elle est
présente parce qu'elle a
travaillé très, très fort.
Elle a developpé son jeu,
son style et elle a développé
ses patrons de gauchère.
Maintenant, on est en train
de le voir, en train de
vraiment bousculer un petit peu
le circuit avec quelque chose
de nouveau.
- Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada,